bonjour misma al adab merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nous ce matin sur
rtl france
on va parler de ce début du ramadan au
liban qui est en pleine crise économique
à ramadan qui débute dans des
circonstances extrêmement être difficile
notamment à tripoli
oui tout à fait alors c'est certainement
une année très très difficile pour
plusieurs raisons oui à l'accord signé
en plus le problème économique que le
liban est en train de traverser et en
plus le problème social parce qu'il ya
une absence totale de la part de l'état
libanais donc le couvre-feu plus le
manque de denrées alimentaires l'état
qui arrêtent pas peu à subventionner les
matières premières qui sont utilisés
savants les choses certainement très
chic et pauvres les les libanais en
général et les musulmans spécifiquement
pendant ce mois de ramadan et on a vu
des files d'attenté devant les
boulangeries à tripoli également le pain
risque de manquer il ya une mouvement de
contestation par rapport à cette denrée
essentielle pour les libanais oui tout à
fait si vous voulez le pain c'est la
denrée essentielle donc c'est ce qui va
voir les gens qui sont plus pauvres que
pauvre il faut dire que je veux de la
ville de tripoli
déjà il ya dix ans a été dans dans le
rapport de l'espoir on parlait déjà de
50% de pauvreté donc ont tiré les
sonnettes de larmes
évidemment dix ans rien n'a été fait
maintenant malheureusement 50% de
pauvreté c'est un peu partout au liban
mais la situation à tripoli devient de
plus en plus compliqué et effectivement
les denrées primordial donc le pain
commencent à manquer de subventions donc
ça devient plus cher
et heureusement il ya quand même une
bonne
partie de la population ici qui
s'organisent pour pouvoir aider les
pauvres et les gens plus que pauvre si
vous voulez donc y ont vraiment besoin
de 2,2 de matières primaires donc le
pain donc
il ya cette espèce de comment est-ce
qu'ils s'organisent
il ya beaucoup de donateurs et beaucoup
de gens qui est de l'étranger de la
diaspora libanaise il faut dire que
l'année dernière le liban a reçu 6
milliards 700 millions de livres
libanais doit excuser moi de dollars
pour les donc à travers les familles
libanaises à l'étranger qui aident leurs
familles présentes sur le terrain c'est
ça qui fait que nous n'avons toujours
pas eu de vraie vandalisme malgré la
situation sécuritaire qui se détériore
mais malgré tout cela le soutien de la
diaspora libanaise le soutien de
certains donateurs internationaux dès
cet été des amis du liban qui vont
directement à voir la société civile la
société civile qui bouge de façon très
importante donc il s'organise qui essaie
de mettre ensemble des des centres pour
faire un dispatching pour pouvoir
essayer de d'assouvir aux besoins de la
population qui de plus en plus pauvres
ça s'organise et ça c'est rassurant
malgré tout la situation difficile que
nous traversons parler de la diaspora et
des personnes qui sont de plus en plus
pauvres le liban n'a jamais connu une
telle hémorragie de ses ressortissants
depuis la guerre des années 80 c'est une
tragédie
tout à fait si vous voulez il ya un
manque de perspective total il ya une
structure politique qui gouverne le pays
donc qui la continuité de des milices
qui ont gouverné le pays pendant la
guerre civile et qui figurez-vous depuis
un an et demi que les manifestations se
font et que la communauté internationale
demande à ce qu'il y ait des réformes
qu'ils soient faites pour pouvoir aider
le liban et rien n'a été fait comme
réforme ils sont toujours dans leur
petite confrontation de politique locale
en essayant chacun de renforcer sa
position politique pour pouvoir
préserver un futur politique qui à mon
avis n'existent plus parce que comme
vous le dites si bien malheureusement
le liban que nous connaissons est en
train de s'effriter et il faut
certainement mettre une nouvelle
structure pour pouvoir regagner la
confiance et de la population libanaise
et de la communauté internationale
on a vu des appels justement pour ce
début du ramadan de la classe politique
à trouver une solution vous y croyez
aucune solution malheureusement et tout
le monde le sait même si un gouvernement
venait à se faire dans ces mêmes
circonstances figurez-vous plutôt que
nous plutôt que d'écouter des
discussions politiques sur le fait de
rassembler un point de vue commun pour
pouvoir discuter avec le fonds monétaire
international
et bien finalement on écoute des idées
complètement farfelu genre est ce qu'on
ferait un gouvernement de dix huit ou
2,24 et qui aurait plus de ministres
donc c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère une
situation c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère
une crise c'est pas comme ça qu'on gère
un pays qui est au bord du gouffre qui
est dans le gouffre on peut plus dire
qu'ils kika pays qui est au bord du
gouffre on est en plein dans le gouffre
et donc il faut absolument des solutions
radicales
il faut qu'il y ait un gouvernement avec
une solution afin d'aider des solutions
de sauvetage qui puisse gérer les choses
importantes à l'intérieur du liban
et puis voir un peu avec la communauté
internationale qui prête à aider et
évidemment en attendant des réformes
intérieures qu'il faut absolument faire
qui sont pas seulement une demande
internationale mais qui sont une demande
de la population locale donc on attend
de 2 de faire ces réformes afin de
pouvoir donner une perspective et
laisser ces gens restés au liban les
libanais laissée au libre
tous les jeunes qui quittent maintenant
aux raisons de quitter malheureusement
si rien n'est fait l'acia 122 plus en
plus compliqué il va de plus en plus de
gens qui vont vouloir quitter le liban
et c'est une bombe à retardement à
laquelle il faut certainement faire face
merci beaucoup on va à la dame d'avoir
répondu ce matin en direct à nos
questions sur rt france